you got your lyrics handy
[Music]
mhm so I have this melody but I want you
to see what you think
about it's got the rooftop
atmosphere
feel
nice another one super
simple how do you spell belir
A I R E I believe wait a minute the E's
on the end of bell isn't it should have
stayed in school for that extra year
forget
stars of
Hollywood big old
house the character is like breathe in
Pang with me baby like it could be a
really bad lyric but it's kind of bang
on for his character come toang County
and we'll go and see see the dolphins
breaching and it's like sexy and
inviting to her she's in Dublin in the
cold and the rain
[Music]
D instead of saying what time she says
no come
[Music]
to your
mouth all whiskey breath and then I'll
leave
[Music]
your they go into a chorus but the idea
of the chorus is you're not going to
come to dban I'm not going to go to La
but what if you built a song and built a
dream of a on that idea maybe we should
in the midle
[Music]
maybe we could find a little
city no one
knows and if we just give us a minute on
no minut
on
home maybe we could it
[Music]
home for a highlight it's got to be a
marriage of of creativity between a kid
who's on garage band who has beats with
the girl who who knows three
[Music]
chords her contribution guitar wise has
to be really simple and the audience
have to go I totally buy that I think
there's notes that kind of hung through
the chorus like
[Music]
mhm
you're she's kind of singing it to the
audience but she's also straining to to
to speak to him and he's coming back to
her I'm a but I'm your and
I'm all you go now he can't you
know and won't sing so it would be kind
of absurd in this movie if suddenly he
was like a a cheer on or something or
thing an act I just love the idea of
little riffs that like felt like okay I
can see a 15-year-old kid doing that
yeah so it's nothing too complex so I
just love that um being the kid he is
living in the flats and hanging out with
the guys doing drill he might do a
little wrap so I've been trying to ride
from the point of view of a 14-year-old
Jilin boy well you you once SW and this
is my best effort this isn't my dumbing
down to try and get into his head this
is the best rap I can do woman guess
we're Cut From the Same Cloth 14 years
in the same block nine long months in
your belly down to the and I still
wasn't ready days L I arrived at the
party smileing me face you're welcome me
hearty back to the GFF in the Liber CHR
party up with the KNE girl we are C from
the same CL all you feel I feel the same
Los we see your Always In The Mirror
Saint angel sinner than I don't have
anything
[Music]
else still here in the High Life bang
and she's like hell you know so if he's
saying what I realized at the end of all
this is actually we dead similar it's
actually weirdly moving yes do you know
what I mean I actually think it can be
for a second you think it's funny and
then it like hits you with a killer
emotional line in the
high living in a high
we're up on the
high and it's a f night to feel
alive